[Music]
this is a song for all the vegetables
that look like penises this is you come
pursue key squash and sometimes even
radishes
we know it's time would you rather like
it's not what you were after
you were food he became a source of
juvenile laughter this is a song for all
the vegetables that look like penises
[Music]
maybe became a source of I don't I don't
know how that happened I don't know
maybe those my gifts inner bacteria for
helping to get us to 100,000 subscribers
or possibly it was my punishment to
nerdfighteria for helping us get a
hundred thousand subscribers depending
on your perspective I guess but what's
very obvious is nerdfighteria gift to me
which is that now I can do that and and
I like have a reason I don't have to
justify my desires to make a song about
penis vegetables with hot colors and
iPod commercial styling no one is even
that I question that that it's gonna be
like oh yeah that's Hank oh I love you
too thank you YouTube and thank you
nerdfighters for making it possible for
me to be weird and not have to feel
weird about it
additionally people who are interested
in a secret project know what that's
about
please go to nerdfighters comm and sign
up for the secret project mailing list
which is down here if you do that our
next 24 hours you're going to get an
email about an important secret project
that I'm quite excited about I just
realized something funny I bought at the
grocery store to use in the video and I
didn't use it in the video um oops now I
have one of these ah I don't even know
what it is that cucumber or zucchini but
I don't know what I'm going to do with
it Oh leave a comment and tell me what
to do with the cucumber zucchini thing
also tell me whether it's a cucumber or
zucchini seriously please nothing
nothing dirty
this isn't equals three people it's a
product of Canada okay videos over I
gotta get to work get it Inc truth or
fail Oh